recently and throughout the last several
years U.S and Iran
are in the midst of nuclear deal
negotiations this is another part of the
story of Iran
is uh the development of nuclear weapons
the nuclear program they're looking to
restore the nuclear deal known as The
Joint comprehensive plan of action jcpoa
what is the history
the present and the future of these
negotiations over nuclear weapons what
is interesting to you in this full
context from the 16th century of the
Messianic
um yeah Journey
um what's interesting to you here you
can argue that for a long time even
under the shaw but much more
expressively and
decisively under the Islamic Republic
there was a
determination to have a nuclear
power or nuclear weapon in a sense I
think the bottom line of all the
negotiations everything else is that
Iran
of the Islamic Republic had the tendency
of
having its own nuclear weapon the reason
for that is that Iran was subject of
nearly nine years eight and a half years
of
uh Iran Iraq War
when uh not only Iran faced uh an
aggressor Iraq that actually attacked
Iran at a very critical time at the very
beginning of the Iranian Revolution
but the fact that Iran felt kind of a
helpless
in the course of this war
and has to make great sacrifices
actually which supported the Islamic
regime and Consolidated the Islamic
regime because of this war
and most of the time
their support of the United States was
behind
Iraq Visa of Iran
and Iran felt that it's been
isolated and has to
protect itself so there is some argument
for
having a nuclear capabilities
but in reality this has resulted in as a
completely mindless crazy
a wasteful attempt on the side of the
Iranian regime
to try to develop a nuclear power and
therefore the rest of the world
particularly in this region were very
worried that if Iran would get access
to a nuclear weapon then the entire
region of the Persian Gulf
might particularly Saudi Arabia possibly
turkey possibly Egypt all of them may
require
uh may may demand to have also nuclear
weapon given the fact that Pakistan and
India has already have it
so there was a determined attempt as you
might know on the side of the western
communities or now gradually World
communities to try to
as much as possible to control Iran from
getting access to a nuclear capability
or actually limit Iran's nuclear
capabilities to what was defined usually
in a euphemism as a peaceful fashion
okay
uh that being said there was also Israel
which viewed the Islamic Republic as a
arch enemy
and some of it might be due to the
israeli's own exaggeration
of Iran's threat and some of it is
because Iran has developed a fairly
strong military as we see today
and as such this attempt to try to
prevent Iran
from Ever Getting access to a nuclear
weapon which resulted as you might know
in this massive
sanctions that were imposed upon Iran
ever since the beginning of the
revolution in 1979 and of course more
intensively since 2015 2016 even prior
to that probably a little bit earlier
this this agreement the nuclear
agreement was supposed to
control or monitor
Iranian nuclear industry or nuclear
setup
in exchange for removing the sanctions
what this never worked in a matter of
fact in a very successful satisfactory
way for the Iranians or for the
Americans particularly under Trump
Administration which I think foolishly
decided to scrap
the agreement that was reached under
President Obama
like many other policies that was
implemented under Trump Administration
this created a major problem that is how
to
under Biden how to try to
come up with a new
nuclear agreement with Iran
in this process since 2016
where the United States withdrew from
the agreement
Iran felt comfortable to try to go and
do whatever they want without any kind
of monitor being monitored by the
International Community
and that's the situation now we don't
know whether Iran is really
sincere under the present regime
to negotiate a deal we don't know that
every United States is
willing to do so
and it seems that now what is happening
in terms of the protests in the Iranian
streets makes it even harder
in a public eye to try to negotiate a
deal with Iran because that means in the
minds of many
and with some justification
that uh
if the nuclear agreement would result in
the removal of many of these sanctions
millions billions
uh as the result of the removal of the
sanctions and Iran's ability to sell it
it's all in the international market
without any restrictions
means that the Iranian government is
going to become even more powerful
more financially secured in order to
suppress its own people
so that's the agreement that goes
against
coming to terms with with uh Iran but
the problem is that there is no clear
alternative even I'm not particularly
personally favorable
for this agreement to be uh to to be
ratified
but the alternative is very difficult
there's no way to try to see what can be
done